hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play forbidden dot
exe alright this is a game that I got
off a game told if you want to play it
right now check the link in the
description otherwise join me for this
little journey did you understand the
last sentence correctly you were the one
held responsible for all the damage the
game will do oh let's not get ahead of
ourselves game by the way have you ever
considered how dangerous it is to run
random software from the internet on
your computer oh or no I've always
wondered what it would be like to play a
video game if the stakes were higher say
your computer for your example for
example no I love my computer I've got
nothing left to live for if I lose my
computer so I decided to test it and
you're playing it unfortunately I can't
let you leave now that would ruin the
suspense but this is really good if you
play my game through I'll make sure you
every file in your computer stays
untouched
oh oh oh die in the game or try to quit
and I'll format your hard drives
instantly Oh No
have fun and watch out for Dave he's the
black thing haha oh and in case you were
wondering would I really do it the
answer is yes I figured it's worth
destroying a few computers to create a
new genre in computer games oh lordy
wait a minute
wait a minute how do I move maybe moving
we're doing to me
let out of me I can't move
what are you doing hey you wanna you
wanna maybe you wanna maybe let me do
some drag oh well that's not good
ha ha oh it's a ma it's a MIT it's like
a ah god I god I never thought that I
click-and-drag I never thought that this
would be like it ah get away get away if
I touch the walls he goes faster
uh-uh-uh-uh
go go you [ __ ] you [ __ ] I'm so calm
and smooth and perfect hi guy no no no
he's gonna get me he's got a format my
drives which is totally reasonable I
guess I know not out my drives I'm not
good at these make hey back off
stop sang in me what are you the dog
whisperer get away from here well this
isn't what I was expecting at all I was
expecting something like actual yeah god
damn it ah
bolos oh there goes my other Drive
well whatever then getting files deleted
left and right is not fair at all
I need up most concentration guys so
Wyatt
be quiet okay there we go hardest part
is over I think and there we go oh come
on
hey look it's my Firefox oh do I go
there who are you what's going on
I'm mr. Firefox and you're inside your
computer and there's a maniac on the
loose trying to kill you
me and your computer okay so how do we
stop him go talk to internet explorer
he's connected he knows everybody in the
system if there's someone who knows how
to stop the crazy make the heck
it's that fat-ass Explorer oh it's crazy
person No
goodbye Firefox I hardly knew you are
schnikeys that's not right either oh no
Pig okay
I'm begging you I'm children look at the
poor blah oh ha oh no well I don't
remember having all that many PDS but no
I don't think I will we know yes ha ha
this is more this is a more comedic
scary game than an actual horror game oh
come on that's frickin impossible this
is the upper wolf [ __ ] you this is
bloody bleedin impossible
it's like that scary maze on the
internet where like it's a jump-scare as
you try to very carefully navigate
through it
ah da da da Dada I didn't mean to
animate go off screw you what the hell
I think women think damn it this is
gonna be impossible I don't have the
patience or the skill to deal with this
I'm simply a woman
Oh Nikes ha ha ha now go go go go go go
go go go go go go come on Heather oh did
you guys think that this was gonna be a
[ __ ] rage game how about you God God
just this thing it's blocking my wrist
it's making me like it's for comfort
design for the [ __ ] yo I never thought
I'd be playing up Oh screw it know I'm
now I'm used to playing with it so it's
just like that's a it screw you either
way I'm gonna die no matter what I'm
just I'm totally boned
on
be careful take your time you got all
the time in the world
there we go oh look it's Internet
Explorer
oh man
finally you're here whoo only leverage
between my head we're now he's finally
going let him Hey
oh you probably won't come we're back
with him there's a solution
I find the game's little found a little
back out of there oh no I got some
partying to do hi
you're a dick I hope he eats you what do
you didn't eat you what is this [ __ ] is
such bull
this is such bull I do not like this
all the time in the world just take it
nice and slow
all the time in the world let's do this
on the first try not have to deal with
douche make bad guy full al is almost a
mistake oh god please don't touch the
sides
haha I have an aunt I mean I haven't
even had a chance to even think about
like commenting on the game itself Oh
mister please save us from the hobo
blocks nothing Oh
just learn away from me ah what the hell
give me a chance screw you people for
don't talk to me I'm trying to go away
sorry I will sacrifice you [ __ ] no no no
okay I'm too young nah don't come after
me you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] go
away go away go away go away that's what
I thought
Wow is the ugliest thing ever seen it
has to be the game's files alright then
come out come out wherever you are
how dare you push my privates that
should make you pay for your ignorant
pigments Dave get your ass here alright
Dave come on gimme come and get me more
come on gonna let me give me dude what
do you think you're doing
Dave Dave you're killing both of us sit
I should have go to the battery I
goddamn
all right okay not what I was expecting
in terms of a game so like I don't know
I don't exactly know what to say about
that that was that was interesting to
say the least I always I always liked
creativity but personally I don't like
those types of games it's contrived
gameplay it's like but I did it I did it
nonetheless I did it and I finished it
so take that for what it is so you can
play the game for yourselves maybe there
was some other things I could do to
actually try and save some of the other
ones but I don't know I didn't do it
very well so I was just happy I could
get through because my hand was like
cramping up I was getting that feeling
in my gut that I hate when I do in
trying to do precision stuff that's all
anyway so thank you all so much for
watching click the interface with more
videos it I've done as always I will see
you in the next video bye
ah
buzz
Oh
yes